♪ ♪
>> Tucker: KAMALA HARRIS HAS
PLANS FOR YOUR GUNS, BUT MORE
THAN THAT, SHE’S WILLING TO
THREATEN CONGRESS IF THEY DON’T
MAKE A LAW THAT MATCHES HER
DESIRES IMMEDIATELY.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE IN THE
MANDATORY BUYBACK OF "ASSAULT
WEAPONS?"
>> I DO BELIEVE WE NEED TO DO
BUYBACKS AND I’LL TELL YOU WHY,
THEY ARE WEAPONS OF WAR WAS NO
PLACE ON THE STREETS OF A CIVIL
SOCIETY.
>> I WILL GIVE THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS 100 DAYS TO GET THEIR
ACT TOGETHER AND HAVE THE
COURAGE TO PASS REASONABLE GUN
SAFETY LAWS AND IF THEY FAILED
TO DO IT THEN I WILL TAKE
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> Tucker: MANDATORY BUYBACK,
THAT MAY BE THE GREATEST
FORMULATION EVER.
IT’S LIKE "MANDATORY DONATION."
IT’S THEFT.
ITS SEIZURE.
OBVIOUSLY.
SO WHY DOES KAMALA HARRIS WANT
TO SEIZE YOUR GUNS?
FOR THE BABIES, OF COURSE.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE SMART GUN
SAFETY LAWS.
AND WE CANNOT TOLERATE A SOCIETY
AND TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY WITH
ANY LEVEL OF PRIDE WHEN OUR
BABIES ARE BEING SLAUGHTERED.
>> Tucker: BABIES ARE BEING
SLAUGHTERED.
OKAY, CLEARLY WE HAVE MISLABELED
KAMALA HARRIS.
TURNS OUT SHE’S ONE OF THE FEW
PRO-LIFE DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE.
AN ATTORNEY, SECOND AMENDMENT
ADVOCATE, WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM ON TONIGHT.
MR. MARTIN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IT’S FOR THE BABIES.
KAMALA HARRIS CARES ABOUT THE
BABIES.
YOU OBVIOUSLY DON’T CENTER FOR
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
DEFEND YOURSELF.
>> [LAUGHS]
LET’S GET ONE THING CLEAR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AREN’T REALLY
TALKING ABOUT, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT A POTENTIAL KAMALA
PRESIDENCY, NOT SO MUCH A
JOE BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
HIS MENTAL ACUITY IS BY FAR IN
QUESTION.
THAT BEING SAID, SHE’S TALKING
ABOUT GUN CONFISCATION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE, WHO
ARE NEW GUN OWNERS, IT’S A GUN
CONFISCATION.
SHE TALKED ABOUT A MANDATORY
BUYBACK BUT SHE DID AN INTERVIEW
IN 2019 WHERE SHE SAID SHE
SUPPORTED A FORCED GUN BUYBACK.
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A GUN
CONFISCATION.
SO THEY CAN USE WHATEVER PRETTY
FANCY WORDS AND EUPHEMISMS SHE
WANTS TO USE BUT WHAT SHE’S
TALKING ABOUT IS LITERALLY
TAKING PEOPLE’S GUNS AND I THINK
PEOPLE REALLY NEED TO GRASP THAT
THAT.
>> Tucker: CAN I ASK YOU A
QUESTION?
THIS JUST OCCURRED TO ME, SHE’S
CALLING FOR GUN CONFISCATION,
MANDATORY BUYBACK.
THAT WILL BE ENFORCED WITH GUNS,
RIGHT?
SHE WANTS TO USE GUNS TO
THREATEN PEOPLE UNTIL THEY GIVE
UP THEIR GUNS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE AN IRONY
EMBEDDED AT THE CENTER OF THIS.
>> SHE IS NOT INHERENTLY
ANTIGUN.
SHE HAS ANTIGUN FOR YOU AND DIE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO HER HAVING
GUNS OR WHOEVER SHE HAS ENFORCE
HER LAW, SHE DOESN’T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
END OF THIS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE BABIES, IT REALLY DOESN’T.
THEY REALLY WANT TO TAKE ALL OF
THE GUNS.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS EXTREME BUT
LET’S THINK ABOUT IT FROM A
NUMBERS STANDPOINT.
LESS THAN 1% OF THE GUN DEATHS
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE COMMITTED
WITH AR-15s WHAT SHE WANTS TO
BAN.
WHAT SHE GOING TO SAY NEXT?
WHENEVER WE HAVE ANOTHER
SHOOTING THAT HAPPENS TO HAPPEN.
SHE’S GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO
HANDGUNS NEXT BECAUSE LESS THAN
1% OF GUN DEATHS IN THIS COUNTRY
HAPPEN BY WAY OF AR-15s.
>> Tucker: WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
HOUSEHOLDS AND COUNTIES THAT ARE
NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN
HAVE AR-15s?
LIKE A TON.
ISN’T THAT REALLY THE POINT?
SHE’S DISARMING PEOPLE WHO DON’T
VOTE FOR HER.
>> PRETTY MUCH.
THE THING ABOUT IT IS WHAT’S
INTERESTING IS RECENTLY THERE
HAVE BEEN A WAVE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE OTHERWISE ANTIGUN ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO VOTE FOR HER
WHO ACTUALLY WENT OUT AND BOUGHT
AR-15s RECENTLY WHO DON’T EVEN
REALIZE HER TRUE STANCE ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> Tucker: REALLY QUICK, DO
YOU HAVE THE NUMBERS?
I CAN’T REMEMBER THEM BUT THE
NUMBER, THE INCREASE IN GUN
PURCHASES IS WITHOUT PRECEDENT,
LIKE IT’S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> I’VE BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR
ALMOST TEN, 12 YEARS NOW AND
I’VE NEVER SEEN IT.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
PEOPLE WHO DON’T WANT TO BUY
GUNS ARE BUYING THEM ANYWAY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
>> I HOPE THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
CONTINUING TO VOTE FOR PEOPLE
LIKE KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN
IS EFFECTIVELY THEM TAKING THOSE
GUNS AWAY.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN’T HAVE NO
POLICE AND NO SELF-DEFENSE, THAT
DOESN’T WORK.
BEEN INSTRUCTED TO SAY KAMALA,